il y a plein de gens moi je reçois des
mots des gens disent on condamne les
actes terroristes euh mais qui
reviennent sur l'histoire mais oui
est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est le
truc c'est qu'il y a ple de gens qui
disent est-ce qu'il faut condamner pour
l'instant il faut juste condamner les
actes terroristes c'est c'est ça que que
disent les gens qu'est-ce que tu en pens
il faut condamner les actes terroristes
sans oublier le poids d' l'histoire et
et sans oublier effectivement que le
peuple palestinien est réduit à deux
bande comme ça et on peut pas nier ça
encore une fois moi moi tu vois par
est-ce que tu est-ce que tu connais bien
le sujet mon alors je connais pas assez
le sujet pour disserter un quart d'heure
mais je connais assez le sujet pour dire
pour dire que la manière dont le
gouvernement israélien très récemment a
géré le conflit avec une colonisation
forcée a accru les tensions
voilàors on des mots qui la propagande
depuis des années on n pas colon chez
soi quand on est chez So on colonise pas
maintenant qu'on gère la proximité de la
bande de Gaza qui est administré à 100 %
par le Hamas depuis 2005 c'est un sujet
mais on n'est pas colon chez soi si
demain tu achètes un terrain de 1000 m²
tu fais une maison et tu décides de
faire une petite mise à côté on va pas
dire oh tu es un colon mais non tu es
chez toi excuse-moi fr là vous faites de
l'idéologie non je non je combats vous
savez ce que je combat le
révisionnisme il y a eu le révisionnisme
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale on a
dit que les Juifs avaient inventé la
Choa aujourd'hui on fait de révionisme
c'est quoi on invente que c'est un pays
d'apartide on invente c'est un pays de
tueurs d'enfants c'est incroyable à quel
point cette propagande se propage depuis
des années il faut aller en Israël ne
ser qu'une seule fois pour s conta on a
menti aux g franc qui qui déjà été en
Israël ici d'accord'est- alorsou mais
non mais ce que je voulais dire aussi
parce que je voudrais que les choses
soient é voilà c'est vrai que les
Palestiniens vivent dans des conditions
compliqué je pense que tout il faut pas
mettre les choses sur le même plan on
parlait ce soir de la Barb Paris de la
condamnation de la violence quand on dit
Mbappé quand on interpelle tous ces
jeunes qui sont des exemples pour la
population française et on sait que ce
conflit a une résonance directe chez
nous il y a il y a la condamnation et
puis ensuite il y a le temps de la
politique on a je parlais des États-Unis
et de la responsabilité des ÉtatsUnis il
y a aussi la responsabilité des pays
arabes comment peut-on quand on a une
grande puissance arabe laisser tomber
ces Gazaoui qui vivent très mal depuis
des années on déverse l'Union européenne
déverse de l'argent avec des des sommes
considérables pour le Hamas ça sert à
financer des roquettes ser pas
gerer prendre l'argent pour faire des
Roques qu' peut pas prendrearg pour
les aujourd'hui le débat cy concernant
le financement le fléchage du
financement de l'Union européenne à au
Gazaoui on est en train de de se
demander s'il faut pas couper cet argent
là et bien on la vérité c'est que Gérard
larch l'a dit ce matin c'est le deuxè
personnage de l'État le patron du Sénat
il a dit non je je ne peux pas vous
garantir madame que l'argent ne va pas
au terrorisme donc on le sait c'est un
problème parce que s'il va pas au
terrorisme y a quelqu'un qui nous dit il
y a quelqu'un qui nous dit va au
terroris pardon il va pas au au social y
a quelqu'un qui nous dit il y a une
frontière avec l'Égypte que le Hamas
ferme pour justement vendre la
propagande c'est ce que je en train de
dire tout à l'heure en parlant de
l'Égypte il y a une vraie responsabilité
l'Égypte il y a une porte qui qui est un
coup fermé un coup ouverte qui permet de
faire une cocotte minute voilà c'est un
corridor qui permet de faire une cocotte
minute tout en en disant après c'est de
la faute d'Israël que voilà euh
évidemment que la la condition les
conditions de vie euh dans la dans la
bande de Gaza sont déplorables mais je
vous rappelle qu'au mois d'août
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait les Gazaouis
ils ont fait des manifestations contre
le Hamas le peuple lui-même et C ces
manifestations ont été réprimé par le
Hamas dans des conditions ex enfin
absolument abominable même tu enfin il y
a la a la NBA qui a posté un message euh
pour euh voilà il y a également Floyd
mewezerin le le le le boxur il a envoyé
des jets privés remplis de provisions et
d'équipement à Israël c'est bien euh
juste quand comment ça parce que il y a
des roquettes qui sont faites il y a des
tunnels est-ce qu'on peut pas prendre
cet argent aussi pour aider euh mais le
problème c'est qu'il est détourné de
partout l'argent qu'on donne qu'on donne
à la bande de Gaza est détourné par le
Hamas l'Autorité palestinienne en
6jordanie avec les leaders qui vivent au
Qatar ou ailleurs cet argent est
détourné au profit de quelques puissant
quelques familles Marmoud Abbas
président de l'Autorité palestinen il
n'est plus rien non le le truc qu'il
faut dire c'est que le blocus il est
aussi euh exercé par
l'égypteà joue un rôle très ambigu
depuis très longtemps et et là en ce
moment c'est fermé alors que des gens de
la bande de Gaza voudraient fuir mais
l'Égypte fer le cor ce que disent les
gens sur les réseaux moi y a il y a un
discours qui ressort c'est il condamne
vraiment les actes terroristes et ils
pensent et tout ce qui s'est passé ils
disent que c'est des actes de barbarie
je crois que j'ai jamais vu ça moi je
vous le dis j'ai jamais vu ça voilà avec
des images que j'ai vu les images que
j'ai vu je n'ai jamais vu ça de ma vie
et je pense qu'on est nombreux à ne
jamais avoir vu ces images et il y en a
et ils disent dans le même temps ils
disent c'est les Palestiniens justement
les citoyens et les civils palestiniens
qui vont aussi trinquer dans les
prochaines heures les prochains jours
est-ce que vous répondez à ça Fran
tapillon B en fait aujourd'hui il faut
bien comprendre que le ramas est
responsable de tout d'abord l'ession
terroriste et vous allez et aujourd'hui
de mettre de faire de prendre en otage
la population palestinienne pourquoi
parce que l'aripost israëlienne est
inévitable c'est une guerre et donc ils
savent très bien que Israël risque de
tout perdre parce que ils sont obligés
d'aller taper pour récupérer leurs
otages et en tapant en récupérant les
otages ils vont faire la stratégie des
boucliers humains où ils vont mettre à
l'endroit où il y a leurs otages des
familles palestiniennes avec des enfants
donc ils instrumentalisent leur
population qui va subir la double peine
donc une finé Israël vous imaginez le
dilemme de cette de cette armée qui
avant de bombarder un immeuble et vous
le savez prévi à l'avance envoie des SMS
demande au gens de partir et donc c'est
une armée humaine est reconnue partout
dans le monde par tous les observateurs
et là il les pousent à la barbarie voilà
le piège mais encore une fois quand on a
aujourd'hui il a 10 français par exemple
qui en parle des 10otages Français si on
en
parle tout- que vous avez
dit PL sil PL toi tu es vraiment éneré
pour par
Mar il monent au créneau à chaque fois
et là vraiment c'est c'est un silence
qui est dégueulasse quoi moi tu qui est
tellement un manque de courage là je
sais pas où il est là en train de faire
une t une je sais pas une série pour
Netflix aux États-Unis je sais pas où il
VI mais il nous donne des leçons tout le
temps de courage de genoux à terre
contre le racisme et tout ça et là
franchement il est pas du tout au
rendez-vous pas du tout au rende- il
faut que les artistes son rendre compte
du risque mondial parce que je vrais
juste dire en deux lignes ce qui peut
éventuellement se passer là les
Israéliens à juste titre enfin juste
titre malheureusement c'est comme ça
c'est c'est la règle de la guerre vont
utiliser la force contre Gaza c'est déjà
en cours l'opération elle est déjà en
cours et ce sont les civils parce que la
technique souvent dans ces cas-là c'est
aussi de mettre des boucliers humains de
se servir de la population et d'en faire
de la chair à canon c'est absolument
horrible ce qui va se passer mais
ensuite quelle va être la réaction par
exemple au nord d'Israël ça va justifier
une attaque du Hezbollah qui est l'allié
de l'Iran exactement et qui est l'ennemi
d'Israël donc voilà j'explique un peu
juste et je termine juste par un autre
une autre conséquence mondiale c'est ce
qui se passe entre la Russie et
l'Ukraine parce que là pour le coup
c'est le premier ministre israélien qui
a fait un calcul à mon avis qui est une
grande erreur qui qui a été de refuser
de donner des armes à l'Ukraine pour
essayer d'être copaincopain avec la
Russie problème c'est que dans les deux
dernières années la Russie elle a
toujours parlé au Palestiniens et en
particulier elle a parlé au Hamas ces
deux dernières années donc il se
retrouve un peu démuni et surtout la
Russie aujourd'hui elle va elle est à
peu près tranquille parce le
mondeisraéliens qui sont contre le M
cont c'est un contrefeu et donc vous
voyez que ça fait beaucoup de foyers
donc les artistes ils ont ce rôle là
pour pas que il a aussi des act on
parleran méchon dans dans quelques
minutes que je vais vous donner ma
décision aussi je vais vous dire et je
vais vous dire que pourquoi ça va me
dans la Merde aussi euh il y a
quelques semaines euh Gazaoui ont été
égorgés des gazawi ont été égorgés par
le Hamas il faut le savoir
aussi la plus jeune française enlevé à
13 ans sans ses parents c'est pas
prendre position de dire que c'est
affreux alors on parle elle est dans un
tunnel seul euh pas de savoir ce qu'ils
lui font c'est pour réagir à ce que vous
disiez sur les artistes qui ne se
prononcent pas ça Géraldine que ce ce ce
enfin c'est tellement incroyable enfin
non moi je voulais juste dire un truc
parce que souvent ici sur le plateau
vous savez on parle de la France qui n'a
plus de moyens et qui aide par exemple
l'Ukraine et et souvent on dit Raymon
dit ah mais on n pas les moyens on a pas
les moyens mais moi je trouve que c'est
extraordinaire que la France donne 95
millions d'euros par an à la sjordanie
et à Gaza c'est c'est un honneur mais
juste qu'est-ce qu'ils font cet argent
là comme le disais tout à l'heure très
très clairement Jacques ils font quoi
des routes des écoles ils aident les
enfants ils font des hôpitaux ils font
quoi ou essentiellement
euh par s' vous plaî